okay welcome to the next video will be a
special one because I'll be playing
kingscrusher I was also doing videos on
on YouTube of course and we both will be
doing a comentary so you'll be able to
watch this video and also my video and
you can compare commentary's if you like
so we gonna roam a lot she bind think
this is a new opening between us we
played a couple of bullet games already
and also on some games away did the
comentarii there should be six is a bit
strange in this position i think i
should just take it two tours in the
pawn structure okay what now simple idea
would between be three in order to
attack b7 and also keep an eye on me six
so this looks like a sensible move
another idea would be just to play mc5
some point maybe you can just play be
six ok didn't he didn't go for that what
about c5 now
he cannot play D 5 so this must be a
good move
ok this this is getting weird ok what if
I just just take this of course I could
play Bishop c4 simply
and night but what is he doing this is
just a it can also take I'm not sure bit
irritated here should be good in many
ways actually
yeah business must be good I don't see
any any decent move freely
um I take now 51 simply
I could just go for might be five maybe
a tech d6
it's not easy to see what what he can do
to cover both e6 and d6 but ok i'm
already down minute on the clock so i
need to speed up because it's very
reliable that he will be quicker at the
end so they take now and e5 must be good
okay what now
hmm i don't need to retreat the night
but maybe i should
yeah you will it would go Queen f7 and
try some I think some double king said I
guess I try to go with my nitro G 32 to
cover a bit back inside also he 6 is
still hanging so oh yeah let's play it
simple take on f4 choke on e6 this is
just two pawns
maybe let me clean you for two to pin
foreplay nitey to now does he have a
trick some kind don't think so I've got
everything covered do you fall by the
rook inland mind and if you if he
retreats now i just have f4 yeah let's
take that yeah this looks very secure
now now just g3 and f4 to push back the
rooks
yes 2g 4g 3 I mean of course after all
the H file should be quicker for me to
reach
should at least exchange some material
and now look aged 6 to come this one is
hanging just just some some chicks
again it's gotta be too he's still in a
pin
he takes nods still a pin okay if I take
now on g4 I've been so slow
yeah Brooke and game with the corner but
no time
oh yeah pre-move I Gifford well this is
this is just ridiculous I have to resign
yeah it was just too slow those two
bones up for nothing and completely